[Music]
the greatest threat and the greatest
concern certainly for the Royals is the
forthcoming autobiography because quite
simply they don't know what to expect
how about raw unflinching honesty that's
how the publisher describes Harry's
tell-all spare dropping January 10th an
audio version narrated by the prince
will include 17 hours of Revelations
Prince Harry just being Harry likely
topics is public childhood military
service Mary and Megan and raising
Archie and lilibet but with a 35 million
dollar advance will Harry unveil juicy
Royal secrets that's not going to be for
Harry talking about his philanthropic
work that's going to be the inside story
of being born the spare I think we're
going to see him shed a lot of light on
why he left now to Matthew Perry's book
Bombshells iding the friends co-star who
said no to dating him up here not have a
crush on Jerry so I had to pretend that
I didn't have Jesus did you know
Chandler kissed Rachel yeah okay in
interesting cause this David Schwimmer
Revelation last year seemingly prompted
Matthew to take a sip I had a major
crush on Jen in the 53 year old's Memoir
friends lovers and the big terrible
thing out Tuesday he also accuses his
former Sydney co-star Valerie Bertinelli
of cheating on then husband Eddie Van
Halen with him quote Valerie and I had a
long elaborate makeout session while a
passed out Eddie was not 10 feet away
from us happy thrilled oh it's me
Valerie responded on Tick Tock with
anyone misbehaving their 20s and early
30s are you mortified the actor has also
now apologized for his swipe at Keanu
Reeves implying it was unfair he lived
while friend River Phoenix died quote
I'm actually a big fan of Keanu I just
chose a random name my mistake on
Sundays I would go to open houses and go
to the bathrooms see what pills they had
in there and steal them 65 times in
detox 55 Vicodin a day and now sober
Matthew reveals more tomorrow during
Diane Sawyer's ABC sit down less than
four years after recovering from a near
fatal trip to the ER my colon exploded
there were five people that night that
were put on ECMO machine and I was the
only one who survived
[Music]